[man] You can never return
to Schmigadoon.
♪ Welcome to... ♪
♪ Schmicago! ♪
- Oh, so we-- Oh. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Schmigadoon
was just the first act.
As the high of Schmigadoon
starts to wear off,
the realities of real life
start to set in.
- It occurs to Josh,
couldn't we maybe think about
going back to Schmigadoon?
- But what if we--
- Yes.
This is not the kind
of musical I wanna be in!
- Okay.
- This world of Schmicago
is a lot darker.
- Hello?
- Fans will be really shocked
to see this era of musicals
filled with mystery
and villains.
- Allow me to introduce myself.
- Our characters,
we have darker histories,
darker origin stories.
- Is that a--
a new meat grinder?
- Yup.
- It's sexier, smokier,
boozier, floozier.
- Okay.
- I'm really into this.
Yeah, ring it in, pal.
- I was determined
to bring everybody back
but as a different character,
apart from Keegan and Cecily,
who are still Josh and Melissa.
- It's the mayor.
(laughs)
Hey, Mr. Mayor!
- I don't think
that's the mayor.
- It's like we have
our little troupe
of merry musical players,
and we all get to play
new roles.
- It's sinister,
sexually diverse,
in a wonderful way.
- The music and the lighting
and the production designer
working so well together
in such a beautiful
and mysterious way.
- This season is gonna be nuts.
- They're here.
(exploding)
- These musicals don't have
happy endings.
(gun cocks)
- I'll...
drink to that.